if I could go back I'd tell younger me
you're going to do some pretty great
things but you do not need to be great
all you have to do is be yourself that
will always be enough you only start
really liking stuff when you get good at
it in my opinion and you only get good
at it by doing it a lot of times before
you're good at it this is why I'm a big
big believer in this is that when you
are starting out I think you got to find
the thing that's the pain and like pain
motivates significantly faster and
stronger than pleasure does because
you're sad now you're going to make a
bunch of bad decisions cuz you're sad no
no it doesn't doesn't work like that
you're sad okay you get emotional
sometimes okay now get control of your
emotions and carry on with your life and
sometimes you're going to get hit with
those waves and that's okay